[Musique]
il n'ya à cannes actuellement parce
qu'on a un autre court métrage de fin
d'études qui est au short film corner
qui a été accepté au short film corner
qui donc le marché du court métrage du
festival de cannes
et donc on est venu à cette occasion
avec marie delsart la scénariste du film
pour venir soutenir le film et
rencontrer des professionnels du cinéma
alors respire c'est l'histoire de
d'antoine un jeune homme de 18 ans qui à
la mucoviscidose et qui est passionné de
course à pied et donc il est à l'hôpital
pour une cure et à l'hôpital il va faire
la rencontre d'une vieille dame n'est
totalement acariâtre au fort caractère
ils ont rien en commun et pourtant ils
vont décider de s'enfuir de l'hôpital
tous lés 9
[Musique]
du coup carbon données venir à cannes
pour défendre ce film c'est totalement
inattendu
on pensait pas que le film vous pouvez
venir à cannes même au short film corner
dont c'était une totale surprise donc on
est très très contents et du coup c'est
l'opportunité pour nous de rencontrer
des professionnels de montrer le film
aussi parce que du coup depuis la sortie
de l'école
on n'a quasiment pas montrer le film
puisque ça doit être une première
mondiale ici donc voilà ça va être les
premiers retours des professionnels du
public des gens qui vont pouvoir le voir
donc c'est un gros tremplin pour nous et
on est très content d'être d'être ici au
festival de cannes alors avant de venir
à cannes on avait une image plutôt
papier glacé du festival c'est à dire on
savait que c'était les strass les
paillettes les stars voilà ce genre de
choses on pensait pas qu'il y avait
autant d'ateliers de deux choses pour
rencontrer les professionnels du milieu
donc s'ils ont été très agréablement
surpris de pouvoir voir que voilà
c'était assez accessible pour pour
discuter avec eux pour échanger avec eux
donc donc on a été surpris là dessus on
s'attendait peut-être pas à cet aspect
là du festival
mais après ça ressemble à un énorme parc
d'attractions rock c'est assez spécial
est excitant d'être ici à kent